[Musique]
l'enfant turbulent qui est tout le temps
à courir et albat dans la rue et puis à
celui qui se met dans son coin pour lire
ou acheter les deux mais je me battrai
pas dans la rue mais c'est dans les rues
de neuilly les enfants ne se bat pas
bien triste si je veux vraiment me
rappeler la première émotion due à la
lecture c'est l'histoire de l'éléphant
jim gee dont il ya un ça dira pas grand
chose un probablement mais aux gens qui
nous regardent mahfal l'éléphant ou jim
gee dans ma vie de petites filles c'est
c'est très importante c'était un roman
épisode qui était sur un petit éléphant
qui était pris un qui été capturé et mis
dans un zoo et ça va durer pendant des
mois ou les aventures de l'éléphant du
budget et enfin pour moi ça sur moi ça
avait un tel un tel effet que quand on
allait au jardin d'acclimatation je
voulais plus passer dans les cages enfin
je voulais je voulais plus voir les
lions dans les cases où les plus puis
voir les les sages faire le guignol pour
des villages humain qui leur donnait des
boules de papier dans lesquels n'y avait
rien ça me conditionner absolument mon
attitude vis-à-vis des animaux à l'année
de la jungle stress très important
c'est peut-être une vie politique et de
pousser au livre de la jungle chez pas
mais alors là je pleurais encore je peux
à tout le temps fin juillet au 6 mai
mais j'aimais bien les livres qui me
faisait pleurer violeur après j'ai dû
tomber dans l'époque stupide c'est à
dire
magali tel likouala une période de 18
mois j'ai jamais ouvert delhi depuis je
crois pas que ce pourrait d'ailleurs
vous croyez que cet âge on ne fait pas
de différence entre livre de la jungle
et délits mais ce que voudrait que t'as
pas après ça c'est l'époque bête 14
qu'on fait ça oui il y en a je bête pour
les filles comme les garçons mais
commence un peu plus tôt je crois pour
les filles c'est plutôt et je crois que
le premier à la première rencontre
important c'est le grand mot n'y a pas
de question quand bonne série d'actes
qui ont vraiment parlé de ski je n'ai
pas relu sport scellier a entièrement
enfin cette femme qui était syphilis est
cultivé comme il veut mais c'était
sûrement vrai qui finalement me donnant
ce livre je devais je répète avoir 13
ans et demi finalement le faisait un
hommage afin de maja au fait qu'elle me
croyait capable de comprendre et aimer
et ça je crois que ça compte tellement
ça compte pour toute la vie je crois que
les cadeaux de livres et ça continue
enfin l'adolescence a continué les
adultes c'est pas toujours c'est pas
toujours aussi pure que ça a l'air de
l'être
j'entends par là que je suis sûr qu'il
ya des gens qui achètent des livres pour
les donner à quelqu'un tu parle pas des
vraies amitiés ou des vraies histoires
d'amour je parle des contacts sociaux et
des géants qui ce qu'ils se disent tiens
si je lui donne c'est à dire il va
comprendre que je suis quelqu'un de très
intelligent
je crois qu'il ya un peu trop à ça on
oublie on ne sait pas c'est pas de ce
n'est pas cela que je pense moi c'est
comme l'a fait enfin on m'a donné les
banques savent pertinemment que les gens
qui me les donner les hommes poilus et
penserait que j'allais avoir de une très
bonne opinion parce que justement c'est
ce livre a qui me ferait chier tandis
que dans les vraies histoires d'amour
d'amitié qui sont humaines avoir besoin
de faire partager aux gens qu'on aime
et joie qu'on a eus d'un livre c'est
très important je crois à part les
lectures conseillées à l'école qui font
qu en philo on dit on dit à la petite
madeleine de combret dieu que c'est beau
et je défie ah ouais que les gens soient
beaucoup plus des génies que je me suis
je défie des élèves de philo d'avoir lu
entièrement post on en lit des morceaux
choisis on les commandes ont cassé après
pendant vingt ans on peut dire dans les
salons il faudra que je relise post
il faut d'ailleurs pas ce qu'on me dit
on voit que je relise alors que très peu
de gens l'ont lu et quel savoir que ça
ne tient qu'à 80 mille exemplaires a été
publiée pour avoir quand même assez peu
de gens l'ont alors ouais à force de
prendre en flagrant délit de dire comme
ça dans les soirées mondaines il
faudrait que je relise il ya deux ans
quand même je les lui il ce match dure
un mois et demi c'était formidable
sachez donc ça c'est autre chose c'est
de passer c'est le tour aujourd'hui mais
sera clos alors les deux grands les deux
grands morceaux qui sont le vrai
choc et qui sont responsables de d'une
bonne partie de ce que je suis en bien
ou en mal
c'est les thibault et bien entendu c'est
la condition humaine
et si vous martin du gard avec condition
humaine de malraux et ça c'est vers
kenaz ça c'est très exactement et ça
correspond à la rend plus à des tas de
choses qui qui n'engagent pas que moi
mais qui nous engageait tous ça
correspond avant loyers de philo c'est à
dire ça corresponde la guerre de 39 et
je crois qu'ils pour un jeune citoyen
français lire les thibault et la
condition et finir les thibault en juin
ça conditionne toute une ville ravagée
la presse alan elle mais je le suis
parce que je je
je crois vraiment que ça que ça a été un
déclic formidable dans ma façon de
penser ma façon de voir les choses
alors contrairement à ce que je hais ce
que j'ai dit des autres livres qui m'ont
impressionné
celui là je l' ai relu tous les cinq ans
je me force pas mais tous les cinq ans
je me refais les thibault complètement
parce que on évolue en et en changeant
le chercher tout change mais ça reste
formidable mais les thibault c'est tout
de même assez long à lire et vous avez
vous l'avez lu d'un seul d'une seule
traite
j'avais dévoré son pupitre je continue
pour les cours qu'il ne pensait pas je
le désirais quand même comme certains
débordements policiers
et puis alors la condition bon quoi que
soit la condition à la relecture je ne
sais pas si ça ferait plaisir mais n'en
sais rien je pense que je suis pas la
seule à lui dire ils les responsables
entièrement de l'engagement d'une
certaine génération vers une certaine
gauche
qu'il le veuille ou non enfin c'est
comme ça et pas autrement
bon alors après après après ça compte
plus parce qu'après les découvertes en
face si vous si tenté que cette
conversation qu'on ait soit par rapport
aux livres qui vous déterminant dans
votre vie soit à partir de stage et on
est déterminés et que alors on a des
émotions on a les livres qui font rire
mais qu'il faut pleurer encore merci il
vous bouleverse qui vous apprennent des
choses mais c'est fini pour se faire une
tête ou un coeur c'est c'est déjà fait
mais il n'y a pas eu tout d'un coup un
livre qui après plus
d'influencer considérablement dans mes
pensées d'un mais non je dis bien les
livres qui m'ont bouleversé des eskimos
mais qui m'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas eu
un rôle déterminant fin quand je disais
tout à l'heure que j'ai j'ai lu enfin
proust pour ne plus me prendre en
flagrant délit de mensonge
j'ai été émerveillée pendant un mois et
demi de deux de découvrir des choses
dont je croyais que j'étais laisse la
seule détentrice un faible par rapport à
la mémoire et par rapport à la
sensibilité par rapport à la jalousie
n'importe quelle chose c'est un peu tard
pour découvrir ça mais j'ai jamais trop
tard pour bien faire mais j'ai
simplement découvert ça mais je veux
dire ça m'a pas ce même pas changé
tandis que les livres dont j'ai parlé
m'ont ils m'ont changé ils m'ont formé
comme comme les gens qu'on rencontre
vous farm nommé par exemple parfois je
me dis il ya peut-être quelque part un
livre que je n'ai pas encore lu mais qui
va complètement bouleverser ma vie au
nom magie avait pu être bouleversée par
hannibal peu et je peux de nouveau
plaint mais comme tu pleurais quand
j'étais petit mais je n'avais pas
bouleverser ma façon de penser
non donc avec votre vision du monde
maintenant est complètement formé qu'il
n'y a rien qui puisse la transformer les
chiots jamais tu ne penses pas les
lectures
[Musique]